Olá eu sou completamente apaixonada por
inovação e tecnologia inovação e
tecnologia mais cedo ou mais cedo vai
fazer parte das nossas vidas já não é
novidade para ninguém o meu papel aqui é
te ajudar a simplificar e se identificar
esses termos para começar a aplicar isso
agora você já parou para pensar o quanto
que as nossas vidas mudaram por causa da
Inovação e da tecnologia processos
métodos produtos a forma de criar
negócios e de pensar o meu e o seu
futuro eu venho de uma família muito
grande eu sou mineira da turma do
cafezinho e sou muito curiosa Essa é uma
das coisas muito importantes sobre mim
provavelmente esse explica como como
economista foi parar na mão da
tecnologia meus pais Maria das Dores e
volta e me tiveram do
os filhos extremamente criativos Eu e
meus irmãos dele Caio e minha irmã Clara
cada um à sua maneira fomos incentivados
a buscar conhecimento ainda que não
fosse naquelas coisas tão óbvias e
triviais e aqui vai o meu primeiro
aprendizado que logo logo já conecta com
inovação nenhum conhecimento é
conhecimento jogado fora tudo vira
repertório e quando a gente fala de
inovação mas ainda colocar inovação não
aceita assumir as respostas ela não
aceita as respostas inovação no
dicionário quer dizer a ação ou efeito
de Inovar é aquilo que novo é uma
novidade adicionaria também que inovação
é a arte de resolver problemas dos mais
complexos aos mais simples Você consegue
imaginar como que os humanos mudaram de
vez a forma como a gente vive baseado
principalmente na sua observação e nos
conhecimentos adquiridos que é o
e vamos pensar a Roda a Roda mudou a
forma como que a gente se transportava
fazia agricultura e também vivia nos
anexos a máquina de impressão foi uma
revolução cultural conseguiu fazer com
que a gente passasse e conhecimento
entre gerações e depois veio o jornal e
as revistas Você consegue imaginar o
centros urbanos sem a lâmpada e o
impacto que tem quando a gente consegue
levar energia elétrica para as outras
regiões de um país vou terminar aqui
falando do telefone que foi inventado
criada desenvolvido pelo grandel e que
tinha como objetivo levar a voz de uma
extremidade a outra revolucionou a
comunicação mudou tanto tanto que em
2007 o Steve Jobs quando apresentava o
primeiro iPhone fez a promessa de que
esses telefones móveis poderiam fazer
muito mais do que telefonemas
E aí as coisas que eles fizeram uma
grande inovação também tecnológica não
sabe porque mudou a nossa forma de se
comunicar Agora eu preciso explicar
tecnologia mas não sabe aquela jeito que
tá escrito no cenário tecnologia também
tenho distanciamento temporal percebemos
a tecnologia de formas diferentes à
medida que vamos envelhecer nós vamos
ter no mais experiências tecnologia no
dicionário quer dizer método processo
formas tudo que nos ajuda a criar
produtos e serviços pensando assim
tecnologia é basicamente quase tudo que
nos rodeia e por isso é tão importante
entender que conheceu quando eu falo
sobre essa lógica temporal eu me explico
melhor quer dizer assim quando a
tecnologia surge e nós Não nascemos
ainda somos muito novos é muito difícil
perceber que aquilo é uma tecnologia
e quando a gente tem entre os nossos 15
e 35 anos entre a adolescência EA
Juventude aquela tecnologia faz parte de
quem nós somos ela revolucionária Eco
que é um termo inglês muito famoso para
isso e a gente vai usar aquilo que uma
forma de reivindicação de mostrar quem a
gente a e se até que hoje é criada
depois da Nossa Juventude vemos ela com
um pouco mais de cuidado ela talvez
precisa ser regulamentada precisa ser
cuidada afinal de contas precisamos
cuidar do futuro da humanidade isso se a
humanidade fosse futuro e essa
tecnologia não for atrapalhar tanta
provavelmente já deve ter ouvido mais ou
menos essas pessoas por isso que quando
falamos de inovação tecnológica não
estamos falando de uma sala cheia de
posts estamos falando da história da
humanidade dos avanços que a humanidade
fez e hoje é possível passarmos por uma
revolução robótica genética e não no
tecnológico tudo ao mesmo tempo uma
eu aprendi trabalhando em que a Inovação
nos grandes Ramos e também sempre os que
falam de Ciência Tecnologia é que quando
esse tema de inovação e tecnologia chega
em jornais revistas e rádio já não é tão
novo assim e provavelmente já faz parte
do nosso dia a dia como por exemplo as
tecnologias de aproximação às
tecnologias vestíveis o5g o clipe e até
uma saúde que é um pouco mais digital
e contudo é preciso democratizar o
acesso à tecnologia para que a Inovação
realmente aconteça e Que ela possa ser
uma inovação tecnológica Não podemos
aceitar que metade do mundo fale de nfts
bitcoins no trabalho remoto e uma parte
do mundo não tem essa alinhamento básica
nós não podemos aceitar que falaram que
como as redes sociais Mudaram as nossas
vidas e de como tudo isso é diferente se
metade do mundo não sabe se a internet e
muitas vezes até aqui no Brasil quando
sabem não tem acesso e não tem a menor
ideia de como usá-los o mais importante
é que essa mudança e essa revolução é
sobre as pessoas é como vamos avançar
não mais criando os filhos e não
querendo se você nem desigualdade mas
sim criando futuros possíveis para todo
mundo algumas empresas já descobriram
que isso é importante e avançarem várias
frentes do negócio é por isso que hoje a
gente começa a pensar na transformação
digital não temos muito famoso nos
últimos anos como que eu posso aumentar
a capacidade da empresa em que eu
trabalho ao mesmo tempo que eu consigo
diagnosticar desenvolver e estimular
eliminar riscos e criar uma cultura um
pouco mais inovadora
E no fim a Inovação é o fruto da nossa
interação individual e coletiva é um
processo é um método e depende muito da
nossa forma de ver o mundo por isso é
preciso desenvolver um olhar mais amplo
e que leva em consideração outras
pessoas outras experiências e que elas
possam construir esse futuro a gente
empresas que julgamos hoje extremamente
inovadoras já sacaram isso há algum
tempo e sabem que a Inovação é um monte
de pequeno as coisas vai dar estratégia
ao produto do processo seletivo
Associação das diretorias do marketing
ao desenvolvimento do software
e agora você deve tá me perguntando
muito legal muito bom que existe
inovação Mas como que eu faço para fazer
isso no meu dia a dia das coisas simples
no meu negócio ou até na empresa que eu
trabalho
hoje é sobre a forma que você pensa o
famoso mais 7 você deve ter ouvido falar
de mais 7 também porque eu não tenho
inglês extremamente usado é sobre como
vamos lidar com o mundo que nova cada
vez mais rápido questionando as
hierarquias os paradigmas o status cor o
lugar e como que as coisas não love.is
também podem ligar e fazer com que a
gente descobrir novas possibilidades é o
e rápido é no meu dia a dia poder ser
Amanda que meus pais criaram curiosa
questionador era sempre buscando
entender o impacto das grandes e das
pequenas coisas no dia a dia se eu for
deixar apenas uma ideia sobre que ainda
passam seria essa não deixe que a
curiosidade morra a medida que você vai
crescendo é importante pensar
desenvolver isso E lembre-se à medida
que avançamos precisamos levar em
consideração outras ideias outras
possibilidades eh
o nível fazer mudança no contexto que a
gente tem com os recursos que a gente
tem fazer coisas completamente
diferentes do que foram construídas até
agora a Inovação é muito mais que post
centros econômicos ricos e tecnologia
aplicativo é uma habilidade que hoje em
2021 é tido como de poucos profissionais
mas logo logo você vai precisar dominar
você está preparado para construir esse
futuro
bom obrigada